bonjour et bienvenue dans cet épisode
nous ne parlerons pas de ce mur ni de
semur et certainement pas de ce mur mais
du mur d'hadrien faisant de cet épisode
le premier consacré à de l'histoire
antique pour ça nous nous intéresserons
en raison de la construction de ce mur à
sa mise en place à ces différents usages
jusqu'à son abandon tragique c'est parti
[Musique]
on a tendance à penser que si on
construit un mur c'est qu'on ne veut pas
de ce qui se trouve derrière la vérité
est plus complexe
dans la deuxième moitié du premier
siècle après jésus-christ le nord de la
bretagne est globalement pacifiée et on
trouve des forts romain assez avancé
dans les terres écossaises jusque
strates carreaux et cardyn par exemple
cependant dans les années 80 6 87
toujours après jésus-christ ces efforts
ne sont plus entretenues et de nouveaux
forces ont construit un peu plus au sud
retrait des troupes attaque barbare
que se passe-t-il sous le règne de
trajan qui arrivent au pouvoir en 98
tout l'effort du nord sont brûlés
attention ce ne sont pas les barbares
qui ont brûlé l'effort ça va mais toi à
l'aise merci des troupes romaines on se
retire en plus au sud ont brûlé l'effort
avant de partir ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ya eu un vase you on a
probablement voulu retirer les troupes
pour les envoyer là où elle serait plus
utile en basse par exemple veni vedi
vici
quoi qu'il en soit une nouvelle ligne de
défense se met donc en place en bretagne
plus au sud le long de la state
elle court d'ouest en est et est composé
de fortin et de tours d'observation les
tours de guet c'est essentiel
plus rien ne bouge donc jusqu'à la mort
de trajan en 117 l'empereur qui arrivent
au pouvoir ensuite adrien ne cherche pas
à mener une politique de conquête ça la
différence de ses prédécesseurs
son but est d'assurer la sécurité et la
prospérité de l' empire et cela passe
par le renforcement des frontières le
limes il crée des forts un peu partout
le long du limes et abandonne même
certaines provinces comme la mésopotamie
ou la syrie
carthago delenda est pour cela il décide
de visiter les différentes provinces de
l' empire et il commence par la bretagne
en 122 il est possible en arrivant en
bretagne il est déjà eu en tête l'idée
de construire le mur surtout quand 118
il y avait eu une grosse insurrection
des brigands tess au nord et de leurs
alliés du sud les selles go va et
enthoven
du coup si on fout un mur entre les deux
plus d'alliance possibles malin à la
drian mais à quoi servez ce mur
exactement si on regarde des premiers
plans il ne doit pas être très efficace
pour la défense du territoire parce que
les premiers fortin ne peuvent
accueillir que 40 hommes chacun
l'escaladent du mur semble facile et les
chemins de ronde sont trop étroits pour
servir de poste de combat
pourtant on ne garde pas de trace de
franchissement d'une
ou de destruction des fortins par les
barbares c'était plutôt une zone de
surveillance
si les brigands tess avait voulu
franchir il se serait alors tu es au mur
à l'aller puis à la stonegate plus au
sud est à nouveau au mur au retour quel
intérêt franchement des gosses thibout
cette colo et booth ouais et puis le mur
gêne aussi la circulation des hommes et
les contacts entre les différents
peuples
du coup au deuxième siècle après
jésus-christ et brillante s ne sont pas
romanisée de plus le mur devient une
zone des changes il est parcouru de
portes que certains négociants sont
autorisés à franchir certains jours pour
aller faire commerce au nord moi je dis
que c'était aussi pour occuper les
soldats parce que franchement vous êtes
déjà allé dans le nord de l'angleterre
ils veulent même pas le whisky pour
s'occuper à l'époque alors autant porter
des murs et c'est sûr ça a permis de
donner un sentiment d'importance aux
soldats le grand mur d'hadrien joyau de
la puissance romaine et c'est ma légion
qui participe à la construction
même les pécores qui vivait au tour
était flatté qu'on leur construise un si
beau mur aussi loin de rome imaginez un
peu le nord de l'angleterre un paysage
totalement sauvage et tout à coup bas un
mur monumental apparaît alors que les
constructions en pierres étaient rares
dans le coin ça en jette
panem et de certaines scènes donc pour
résumer le mur est beau le mur et grands
le mur occupent les soldats sécurisé des
frontières et permet de contrôler les
échanges commerciaux il représente quand
même un sacré chantier
alors comment at il été construits la
construction du mur et confiée au
gouverneur ap la taurus dépôt ce même
s'il semblerait que ce soit adrien lui
même qui ai décidé les premiers plans ce
sont des soldats qui l'ont construit
puisque trois légions ont été
réquisitionnés la deuxième
augusta la sixième victime et la 20e
valeria vectrices soit dix mille soldats
environ 10 donc ils étaient légion
le lieu choisi est la ligne entre la
soul wever à l'ouest et la taille à
l'est ce qui correspond à la partie la
plus resserrée de la grande bretagne
en plus c'est une zone assez proche de
la stand gates qui se trouve un peu plus
au sud et le terrain est très favorable
puisqu'on trouve déjà des élévations
naturel à certains endroits qui renforce
les défenses du mur on commence par
construire des fondations de trois
mètres de large et quelques tours de
guet et fort on devine que la
construction a été fait dans cet ordre
parce que le mur de fait finalement que
2,4 mètres de large alors que les
fondations et certains bâtiments en font
trois il semblerait y avoir eu un petit
changement de plan il mesurait aussi
quatre à cinq mètres de haut par contre
à l'ouest ils ont d'abord fait en mode
de tourner parce qu'à l'époque on ne
savait pas encore de la tourbe pour
faire de nice qui fumait ils ont donc
fait des modes de tours de trois mètres
cinquante de haut précédé d'un fossé et
après seulement les ont remplacés par de
la pierre on a retrouvé des vestiges
d'une quarantaine de camps provisoires
dans lesquels étaient logées des soldats
le temps de la construction du mur
ensuite tous les 1000 pas sont
construits des petits fortin pouvant
accueillir entre 25 et 50 hommes les
mâles 14 appelé ainsi puisqu'ils étaient
espacées d'un mille roma en toute
logique entre chaque maille casal on a
aussi construit deux tours de guet qui
pouvait accueillir une douzaine d'hommes
si vis pacem para bellum les bâtisseurs
du mur ont d'ailleurs tellement bien
respecté le plan d'un mike castle tous
les 1000 pas que l'un d'eux donné sur un
précipice ce qui est fort pratique vous
en conviendrez
chaque mâle qu'assad disposait d'une
porte au nord et au sud ce qui montre
bien que le mur était un lieu de passage
et non une frontière fermée
par exemple voici le maca sol deux
copilotes on observe aussi des
différences entre les mailles castle
malgré les plans initiaux ce qui laisse
à penser que chaque légion avait son
propre style ensuite on a aussi
construit d'efforts beaucoup plus grands
qui pouvait accueillir jusque 500 hommes
dans ces constructions ont trouvé le qg
ap les principia une chapelle aux
enseignes où chaque légion pouvait
entreposer ses insignes et son aigle une
salle de réunion la résidence du
commandant quelques appartements privés
des troupes elles logeaient dans des
casernes partager il existait aussi
certains services comme des hôpitaux
atelier écuries entrepôts bon nombre de
ces forts ont laissé des vestiges de nos
jours comme le fort de chester dont on
le plan celui de façade dont vous avez
pu voir quelques photos ou encore celui
d'art biya qui a été en partie
reconstituées
la construction de ces forts a duré
jusqu'à la fin du règne d'adrien à un
kilomètre au sud du mur on a aussi
construit un fossé que les premiers
archéologues ont appelé valou mais alors
que ça signifie remparts à nîmes où ce
mini miss et or est si elle continue
avec ses citations latines je chante en
ancien français se valent omettez large
de s'y mettre profond de trois et on
pouvait le franchir qu'au niveau
d'effort et d'émail castles par un pont
et parfois même par une porte
il semble donc qu'il avait pour but de
protéger l'accès au mur par le sud mais
à l'encontre de qui mystère une fois le
mur terminé légion qui ont participé à
la construction sont renvoyés dans le
sud
et ce sont des troupes auxiliaires qui
en assurent la garde les corvées
l'entretien etc dans l'armée romaine les
troupes auxiliaires son décor composé de
personnes étrangères à rome
ils font partie de l' empire mais ne
sont pas citoyens romains n'exagérons
rien abyss ou s'habille sumino kamei a
remis ses troupes on trouvait des
personnes venues d'allemagne de gaulle
d'espagne d'assyrie de hongrie de
bulgarie etc
on a une idée d origine de ses troupes
grâce aux objets retrouvés près du mur
qui prouve aussi que le commerce
fonctionnait pas mal à cette époque même
aussi loin dans le nord en termes
d'aménagement on trouve un peu de tout
vos murs comme il était traversé par
trois rivières on trouve à l'extérieur
de certains fort des termes mais aussi
des tavernes des boutiques et des
bordels elle est belle la légion romaine
des auxiliaires les soldats n'ont pas
droit de se marier avant la fin de leur
carrière qui dure 25 ans tout de même
beaucoup se trouvent donc une femme sur
place
seules les femmes d'officiers ont le
droit de suivre leurs époux haguenau ce
qu ils atterrissent souvent des villages
se développer près d'efforts dans
lesquels on trouvait donc les familles
des soldats mais aussi tout ce qu'on ne
pouvait pas trouver à l'intérieur des
forts comme les boutiques les artisans
etc
on trouve aussi évidemment des lieux de
culte notamment consacré à mithra un
dieu particulièrement honorés dans
l'armée romaine mais aussi à certaines
divinités locales
en 1973 des archéologues ont découvert
plus de 900 tablettes de bois appelée tu
avais tu devines d'hollande à du nom de
la garnison où on les a trouvés
elles sont rédigées en latin et
constitue un témoignage très précieux de
la vie au mur on y trouve des lettres
des soldats envoyés à leurs familles ou
inversement et donc les noms des soldats
ce qu'ils ont mangé quelles étaient
leurs activités et c'est l'empereur
antonin succède à a brillé en 138 et
décident immédiatement d'une nouvelle
politique il veut abandonner le mur pour
en construire un plus au nord vers 142
il remporte une victoire contre les
peuples du nord et à partir de là il
réoccupe l'effort qui avait été
abandonné par le passé fait construire
de nouveaux avant-postes et un nouveau
mur de 40 milles devant ce mur est
construit par les mêmes régions que pour
le mur d'hadrien s'agit d'un modèle
classique de trois mètres de haut avec
un chemin de ronde protégé par un
parapet en bois au sommet est ponctué de
fortes à une nouvelle brique dans le mur
quoi il était aussi protégé par un fossé
de 13 mètres de large car on n'est
jamais trop prudent
encore une fois ce sont des troupes
auxiliaires qui est le garde durant
l'occupation du mur d'antonin le mur
d'hadrien n'est pas abandonné mais les
portes des mike castle sont démontés
pour faciliter la circulation et le val
ou mais même comblé à certains endroits
après ça c'est un peu le yoyo en 157 les
troupes démantèle des forts du nord pour
repartir vers le nobel rien puis on 161
euros partent au nord en 164 elle re
décembre oui bon ça s'en va et ça
revient il avait sûrement une stratégie
très développée derrière tout ça il est
possible que la guerre contre les parts
est contraint à une redistribution des
troupes et donc moins d'un mur le mur
d'antonin est abandonné mais pas le mur
d'hadrien en 175
on y envoie 175 mille cavaliers sarmates
ce qu'on voit dans le film là mais sans
le roi arthur
c'est ballot oh ça sent le roussi ça il
n'y avait pas beaucoup de cavaliers dans
l'armée romaine alors pour qu'on nous
envoie autant c'est que ça bastonne
sévères contre les barbares et ça
continue jusqu'à la fin du 3ème siècle
où apparaissent les pictes que vous
pouvez retrouver dans cette vidéo de
qualité
eux n'ont aucun scrupule à s'attaquer au
mur tranquille à partir du vème siècle
le mur décline
comme l' empire romain les légions sont
rappelés plus près de rome pour assurer
sa protection et donc les pauvres pécore
qui vivait loin d'italie sont délaissés
on estime à 4 110 la fin de l'occupation
romaine en bretagne cependant tous les
soldats auxiliaires ne partent pas
certains continuent d'occuper le mur
jusqu'à une période avancée du vème
siècle
même si plus aucun ordre ne vient de
rome et d'autres délaisse le mur pour
aller s'installer dans les environs et
devenir paysan mais parce qu'il avait
pas beaucoup d'autres perspectives de
carrière dans le coin les déserteurs pas
étonnant que rome ait chuté
du coup le mur abandonné ses pierres
commence à être réutilisé pour d'autres
constructions comme c'est souvent le cas
des monuments antiques
on en retrouve certaines dans les
fondations de l'abbaye des exams par
exemple ce que c'est qu'un monument
matériels mais sans grand quand même un
peu triste
si ça peut te rassurer aujourd'hui une
bonne partie du mur existe encore
surtout sa partie centrale
il a été classé au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco en 1987 on peut encore se
promener le long du mur visiter les
ruines de certains fort ou my castles et
apprécier certaines particularités du
mur comme ses falaises ou encore cet
arbre ayant poussé dans un creux entre
deux collines et qu'on retrouve dans le
film robin des bois
celui avec kevin costner vu du ciel le
mur a laissé ses marques dans paysage et
on peut observer les traces laissées par
le mur même là où il n'existe plus par
les anciens core romain et même par le
baloum le fossé qui se trouvait juste au
sud
ouais je voulais terminer sur de belles
images parce que ce sont de belles
images
j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu on
se retrouve le mois prochain à peu près
comme d'hab en attendant je vous laisse
avec les petites images qui vont bien et
une chanson qui n'a rien à voir parce
que par une cloche j'avais pas trop
d'idées voilà
à bientôt là
si scott smith australie
[Musique]